centuries have passed but our order has
remained steadfast in its sacred mission
to preserve the balance between man and
half-breed the order 1886 is a big tease
it starts with a cool Victorian setting
introduces werewolves and great guns and
then proceeds to take away the good
skunk the order is cruel in the way it
plays with your expectations
taking a promising idea and then sucking
out all the energy with boring cutscenes
a rage inducing ending and bland
stretches during which nothing is going
on
boring is the best word to describe the
order in general it is as you probably
guessed 1886 and you are Grayson
otherwise known as Galahad one of the
knights of the round table it is a time
of trouble common citizens have begun to
rebel against the gentry possibly a
lying with a race of werewolves the game
alternately refers to as lichens and
half breeds that such a world could be
so lifeless is unfathomable yet the
order pulls it off turning its great
ideas into the dullest game possible you
face lichens early in the game leaping
out of the way and shooting them down
before killing them off for good by
plunging a knife into them and then the
game casts them aside until they're
barely a memory the order pulls them out
of hiding a few more time is mostly for
snooze worthy QuickTime events instead
of you know cool battles as for the
nature of the Lycans where they come
from and all that developer ready at
dawn throws all of that away to focus on
the stale heroes who sit and argue at
the round table every so often what a
shame at least the voice acting is
absolutely excellent far better than
material deserved wither away from this
inaction
David Sebastian Cole should be damned
the credits roll after the button press
that serves as an ending and vital story
threads are left dangling in the wind
it's a rude send-off if you actually
wanted proper conclusion
the order is divided more or less
equally into fourth disparate pieces
cutscenes QTEs navigation and shooting
it strings these features into poorly
paced sequences that have no sense of
rhythm it is the modern action game
personified this is the part where I
walk for three minutes and now comes the
bit where I have to pick things up and
look at them for a couple of minutes and
then comes the brief shooting part that
practically ends before it begins
walking looking and shooting aren't bad
on their own of course what make such
basic mechanics so predictable in the
order is how they're used the downtime
is too often just walking without any
character development or creation of
tension the sequences in which you
investigate your surroundings for
important clues are even more tedious
you trudge about a room picking up
objects and turning them over in your
hand a few weapons aside you're rarely
looking at anything of interest old
photographs of characters you don't know
letters that provide the tiniest morsel
of backstory and so forth the order is
laughably in love with its own object
models you pick up minor knickknacks and
lovingly rotate them as if you have
discovered the Holy Grail I presume that
the order 1886 wishes to build its world
by demanding you admire these details
but the game didn't need to have tried
so hard
it's just absolutely attractive end of
story
the order clearly has cinematic
aspirations the camera is quite close to
your back to the point where you can't
see much once you've taken cover the
game is at its best when it allows
itself to be a shooter which is what
makes its failings all the more
disheartening the thermite rifle is one
of the most interesting weapons in
recent memory letting you fire a round
of magnesium ammo and then ignite it
with a rush of air what a blast it is to
mess with such a unique firearm and what
a heartbreaker to have such grossly
limited use of it the standard weapons
function just fine at least though this
is cover shooting at its most
predictable you walk into a room and see
all the obvious cover spots and sure
enough the enemies come in like
clockwork you shoot them all with ease
and move on to the next sequence there
is a mechanic that lets you slow down
time and Pelt enemies with bull
and another that lets you revive
yourself when you go down if you aren't
shot again both of these mechanics are
incredibly pointless though making it
easy to forget about them and indeed to
wonder why they're even there at all at
its best the order 1886 is perfectly
playable lovely to look at and listen to
a paragon of big-budget development but
it's also the face of mediocrity and
missed opportunities a bad game is one
thing but the order isn't bad it's just
boring everything to your liking thus
far quite just another ordinary London
morning
you